california wants to double its taxes you
okay with that let's talk california
wants to double its taxes
and uh here we have two that live in
florida you right now live in
new york so i double my taxes from you
how awesome is that though but you like
to play volleyball in delray
which is it i'd move here if my wife
didn't hate florida that's right
we discussed this last time
okay so let's see what's going on with
california all right here we go this is
an article from national review you can
also find this article i believe on
washington examiner and
taxfoundation.org but this one is
national review folks if you're living
in california or thinking about moving
to california i don't know a lot of
people are thinking about moving to
california but you might want to listen
to this california wants to double its
taxes
jared walczak of the tax foundation
wrote a block post yesterday with news
that doesn't seem possible californ
california an already high tax rate
wants to double its tax revenue no
matter how he broke it down the proposed
constitutional amendment the numbers are
astounding it would increase the top
marginal tax rate to 18 and a half
percent that's
7.05 percent
higher than hawaii the next highest
state that 12 and 12.75
higher than a national medium it would
increase taxes by an average of twelve
thousand two hundred fifty dollars per
household
all told the new tax package is intended
to raise an additional 163 billion a
year which is more than california
raising total tax revenue any year prior
to the pandemic it's not just income
taxes though the state wants to
implement a payroll tax as well with the
top tax rate applying to taxpayers
making only forty nine thousand nine
hundred ninety dollars in annual income
currently only massachusetts and nevada
have a payroll tax that do more than any
fund unemployment insurance it continues
the most insane part about the proposal
however is the two point three percent
gross receipt tax only seven states levy
gross receipt taxes which are especially
harmful to economic growth because they
are based on business revenue not
profits even if businesses lose money
they still pay the gross receipt taxes
because they still made revenue which is
insane if you ask me if this proposal
adopted california would essentially
have 18 tax brackets and individuals
making less than 50 000 per year wind up
paying double digit marginal tax rates
thoughts mr stossel
i think it's great
because we need we got 50 states it was
a wonderful design so we could
experiment and we need
models of failure so you need models of
failure
so you're saying this is a model of
failure or potential failure well i hope
it will be but it is amazing how
californians can say
i believe i believe government will
solve all the problems and
we'll get the homeless off the street
and we'll
make everything nice and if i'm paying
18
that's okay
i made a lot of money on silicon valley
i can afford it and i'm it's a public
service
now here's a question danielle i want to
ask both of you guys curious to know
what you say i think the question is the
following newsom
when he won the recall he was going
against larry elder and if we remember
that it was convincing victory 64. it
came out of 67 by the time they got
everything it was around 63
62 but it was not even close right
so 60
plus support newsom how likely is it
that something like this could pass okay
wait wait wait wait timeout
there was a fourth stimulus check mailed
to californians right before the recall
vote so they're literally getting 1500
of cash in their bank accounts right
before they go to the polls how
convenient is that and b to john's point
about a failed experiment it failed last
year anybody guess when california was
was entered into the union year 1850
since 1850 the population of california
net net has grown every single year
until 2021. and 2021 was the first time
that they had a net decline in their
population so if they want to continue
on this merry path then they can fail
even bigger yay
and lose even more companies well here's
a question daniel for you
if 60
supported newsome what's the likelihood
that this insane tax proposal will pass
i mean if if it's only the crazy voters
coming out and the other people who are
like screw that or like leaving and they
were on the fence before they were like
if anything else crazy and i've actually
spoken to people out there who have
great companies they make good amounts
of money and they were like well we
thought the taxes were going to go up
we've already bought places elsewhere in
the country and then all the craziness
stopped but they're like if the taxes go
up i'm out of here i've already got my
plan b actually i already owned the
the property outside of the state of
california so a small exodus is going to
become a mass exodus
and do we really know that they
supported newsome because
the press portrayed larry elder is a
crazy man and larry
talks so fast and
puts out so many ideas in one quick
sentence
he turned off a lot of people i love him
and he's right on all the issues really
so you were a fan of
larry elder totally wow except for his
presentation
and i think he scared people fast
talking salesman type of thing is that
okay but california's like new york is a
state right if you're conservative
you're ambivalent on voting day you're
like my vote's not going to count so you
didn't even bother you're like if i
i i registered to vote against hillary
when i lived in new york you know what i
got jury duty
i mean that was it my vote didn't count
it was it was just nonsensical my my
friends were like why are you doing this
why are you giving your texas driver's
license i've been here for seven years
fine and i'm you know she's not even
from new york i'm going to go out and
vote against her to do my duty my civic
duty and all i got was jury duty but
there there's a there's a level of
ambivalence whether you're living in new
york or illinois or california and
you're like my vote if i'm a
conservative my vote doesn't counsel why
bother
yeah but but here's here's here's the
part though number one like
you know the whole theory about the you
put a frog in the water you boil at one
degree slowly and then eventually at 212
he doesn't know it's getting hotter so
he dies like you've heard the story i'm
not the first person telling you the
story right all the time yeah that's not
true yeah and it's not true no the frog
jumps out as it's slowly warm you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna do this
on the podcast as an experiment next
time you're good next time just make
them be serious david tyler make an oat
next time stossel is out here we're
going to bring a frog we're going to put
it in the water we're going to boil it
at 212 frog in a hot plate and we're
doing podcasts when you see the frog
jump out on john it would be hilarious
so that's the next experiment make a
note of it but anyways going back to
this
at what point
at what point are people gonna say
you know there is no freaking way this
makes any sense or is it already
happening elon musk originally moved
personally to texas
and now he's relocated to headquarters
yeah but remember top marginal tax rate
so what is top marginal tax rate because
the person making 42 thousand dollars
are like dude please raise a top
marginal tax rate i don't mind if you
raise a top marginal tax rate so there's
more people making less than 49 than
those that are making top marginal tax
rate so a lot of people at the bottom
they're like silicon valley ain't going
nowhere they're going to stay here
forever right like this whole thing
about what happened in detroit that'll
never happen to silicon valley new york
is the financial capital you know
hollywood is hollywood even though
atlanta and austin's kind of competing
silicon valley silicon valley miami is
becoming the crypto capital there's no
way these billionaires will leave
morgan chase has more more employees in
the state of texas than jp morgan chase
has in new york
um
pat you used that analogy one time and i
think you were getting to it with the
frog is you got upset how much are you
willing to get pushed meaning like if i
do this to you yeah all right it's a
little annoying if i just if i do that a
little bit more and if i keep pushing
yeah and pushing at what point you're
like dude if you push me again i'm going
to knock you out and that's essentially
what's happening here is like oh we'll
raise it a percentage no it's good yeah
but you know what it is here's here's
the perspective here this is what i'm
trying to ask the brains to my left
because i'm a guy with a one point of gp
from high school these guys got degrees
on top of degrees and they're educated
in the world journalists legendary
journalists and federal reserve finance
here's a question
i'm doing it to
you right you're getting irritated but
if those that are making 40 grand you're
watching me do this to the billionaire
guess what they're saying do it again do
it again do it again all right it's
awesome do it again so it's yeah no no
they're excited that i'm pushing yours
they're celebrating it and newsom is
like oh you like it oh you like it yeah
oh wow okay awesome let me do some more
i think that's the dynamic right and and
by the way you know who ends up paying
the biggest price for this not for you
because who wants you
who wants you
49 other states
of course yes yes 49 other states want
you
this guy median income in california 32
000. here's the question i'm saying so i
love your analogy pat but why should the
person making 40 grand who's watching
and to get pushed watching the
billionaires get pushed watching the
millionaires get pushed
why should they care why should they
john
because life won't be as good if you
push the
producers out but why do you think that
the silicon valley won't go down like
detroit if
the economics don't make sense and
people are moving to austin and
florida
nicer places california has
mountains and an ocean and great weather
a lot going for it and bizarrely a
surplus
because the stock market went up so much
and these billionaires are paying more
in taxes
but it could bust
at what point
i don't know
what point is last time i checked the
nasdaq's incorrection
no no i get that but i'm trying like if
you have you studied the history of
detroit on what caused it to break down
when
a mayor
you know started playing games with
dearborn and they started raising local
taxes and regulation and they the union
got involved and started making life
public unions so eventually they're like
we're out of here and the next thing you
know the population went from one and a
half million to 800 000
and all those jobs left to different
places do you really think if that
happens to silicon valley it could
happen and number two is what causes
that i'm going to push one of john's
buttons yeah here we go and in texas
which is like california central because
the influx is insane and it's non-stop
a lot of parents have actually started
to leave talking about strong unions
because the la
uh teachers union
mandated that when they shut the schools
down that they also had to have the
private schools closed as well
and the private schools are like wait a
minute we've got the protocol we can
stay open
and eventually the parents just threw in
the towel and they're like we could
afford to have stayed in california
they weren't bending on critical race
theory so a taxes b i want my children
to have an education that i want for
them to have that not that's mandated
and dictated so i'm getting the hell out
of here so california is hurting itself
in more ways than just economically
incentivizing people to leave is all i'm
saying because when your union is that
strong like it was in detroit and you
have you you a public union gets the
power to close private schools
i mean come on that's not it's there's
nothing american about that
people put up with a lot
most people don't really pay attention
to the stuff we talk about
they
think about sex and music and movies and
sports and raising their families
there's the expression that
percent of the people
one percent of the people make things
happen and
ten percent watch and the other ninety
percent wake up and say what happened
and people don't notice that their taxes
go up a little bit a little bit a little
bit they just take it yeah but i mean
patrick if you i mean if you're reading
correctly they're talking about doubling
yeah but but but john if you're yeah if
you double so so let's do the math let's
just say i'm paying
5 000 in taxes and i'm making 50 a year
that goes to ten thousand dollars in
taxes my car payment is 320.
i'm gonna feel that like i remember when
i'm making 40 grand a year
what a hundred dollars was i looked at a
hundred dollars raised in a month i'm
like dude my phone goes covered next
time that's fantastic so i felt a
hundred dollars at that level but you're
contradicting yourself i know i am i
know i am i'm trying to challenge to see
at what point do people leave that's
what i'm trying to find at at what point
the silicon valley just become a city
event you know and all these guys are
gone what will cause them to leave
i don't know yeah i think it's the same
thing that happens in a relationship
it's that we've all i'm sure we've been
in like relationships that haven't
worked out and you get in a fight it's
like all right cool whatever it's a
fight and then you get another fight or
whatever and you're getting a fight
you're arguing and it's fighting and
then at what point you're thinking i
don't know if i want to be with this
person i don't know i don't know it just
kind of keeps happening and finally boom
something happens and you're like all
right that's it i'm i'm getting the so
it's not a one and done thing we got in
a fight we're done it's the cumulative
effect you meet someone else
you see a nicer sexier state out there
something like florida comes and winks
at you to your point
i mean at some point you're going to get
so frustrated that you're waiting
forever to get into a restaurant
because the support staff is simply not
going to be there anymore because you've
you've expanded the social safety net to
such an extent right the only fourth
stimulus check in america was in
california otherwise the rest of the
nation just got three and that was way
too many
but that was a state federal it was a
state a state okay it was a state but at
some point you're going to get so
frustrated if you're a zillionaire
that that you don't have
the service that you want you can't go
to napa valley
and go to your favorite restaurants and
go to your favorite resorts because
there there aren't enough workers
because the social safety net is big
enough to capture them to where they
don't have to work
it's at some point things start to fall
apart that's just like new york right
now i mean you wait a lot longer
at a restaurant for service and either
you want to be there you don't
you know you know what this makes me
think about it this makes me think about
in a following way how many people can
handle domestic violence
how many how many marriages do you know
where people are like you know what [ __ ]
this sucks but i'm not going anywhere
how many people stay in a marriage with
the message that was kind of my point
with the relationships
that's at his point but you also have
women's shelters that that are
constantly full so clearly human beings
hit their break points or the women's
shelters wouldn't be full so what i'm
saying is i think california is a form
of domestic violence to its citizens i
think california is the best example of
domestic violence and unfortunately some
are going to take it and tolerate it and
some are going to say i'm getting the
hell out of here unfortunately
the the logic behind the politician
what's the politician thinking about
what is the policy maker thinking about
what is a policy maker thinking long
term like what what's this 163 billion
going to do like you're going to treat
more we're going to help people we have
problems here and if we have this money
we can get more social workers to help
than the neglected kids and
they believe it
clean up the homelessness everything
that's going on in san francisco i mean
we've covered that to uh
i mean at least de blasio left before he
was able to set up the the shooting up
heroin tents the safe spots
i mean this is already going there this
is a question for you go forward and so
i think this is ultimately where we're
going with this is that
physically
john touched on this with the mountains
and the oceans physically california is
the most beautiful state
but
tax wise and politically it is
potentially the ugliest
state you see what i'm saying there
would you agree with that sure
so so you're like you moved out of
california for seven years but it's for
you it's kind of like you're dating
somebody who's dropped it gorgeous who
is ridiculously demanding
and nothing ever makes her or him happy
yeah how long are you gonna understand
that that's my point is that you can
brag about her in front of everybody
else but she's horrible to my friends
and she's horrible to my family and i
can't like and honestly she's probably
also horrible in bed you know
you know i'm just putting it up because
people hear about how maybe
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]